好 這一次的跌勢
最近是加速沒有錯
但是之前這樣跌壓
6月就震盪囉
到現在真的挺折磨人的
小哥上次來有提到地板股不多
今天來超級多
超級多的一天
超多
我們要控制情緒
有一次在搶地板股的時候
你笑得很高興
結果你真的很興奮
興奮到有點發抖這樣
隔天漲停
隔天漲停就算我們被罵了
好 被動元件
國際政壇開發說
等一下有最新消息會隨時補充
很多又再跌停了
你說如果是處置股又打四折
隨時準備反攻
0650台大電齊邦已經都是地板股
對 這就算大型的股票
所以這些都有機會
首先我們來看一下
國巨上半年賺8.48元
還可以
從1200塊來看有點少
從500塊來看好像還可以
還可以了
因為他未來Q3還會再成長
所以未來還有機會
不行啦 要火爆成長
火爆成長
對啊 溫和成長
好 合併營收444億元
毛利率38.8%還不錯
營業利率26.4%也不錯
財率三升
看起來都滿正面的啦
對啦
所以我覺得大盤要反攻
要先看被動
因為我們都知道基本面
都是成長的
基本面很好
才會講說哥今天來就是要告訴大家
籌碼什麼時候好
他在高檔
各位看一下
高檔他一直有紅黑K交錯
對啊
這種紅黑K交錯
就是有點這個阻力出貨的現象
邊拉邊出
那後面呢
後面發生什麼事
其實後面很多被動元件
是跌到進入處置
然後跌到進入處置之後再怎麼樣
再繼續跌
繼續跌之後又繼續再延長被關
對 跌到被關
對 被動族群太多被關
現在就有五檔
是 好 是跌到進儲支
買的時候你不計代價就想買到
這個是怎麼樣都賣不掉了
這賣不掉
因為儲支這個你還要
有的要入金 20分鐘要入金
又入金
這個很多人都已經套牢了
都要補保證金了 然後錢還入金
所以這些股票跌到20分鐘的
很多都這個沒有流動性
然後他們的跌幅都非常的誇張
對
跌幅很誇張
各位看華新科是跌65.8%相當於三折三五折三折三折好了這已經打到哪邊打到這個
這個快膝蓋的位置了
所以這邊真的滿慘的
光剪了65%
日電貿易也是65%
以前的腰骨都變成這種
好誇張的腳踝骨
對啊 核四檔好一點 54%
香煉59%
這些看起來
一堆打三折或四折
那這種其實後面都有機會
報復性的反彈
往上彈的時候也沒什麼套
也沒什麼解套賣壓
因為都套得很上面
你套在600塊的
會因為漲到250你想解套嗎
不會想賣
是這個想法
對 因為這段過程中
太多地方是沒有量
這流動性問題會造成超跌
所以報復性反彈
各位你一定要注意初量
只要有出量就有報復性反彈
可是被關哪來的量呢
還是要等出關呢
我大買那天就有量了
哈哈哈
小哥都在周杰怎麼把人家敲開什麼的
對我已經在等了
已經準備好穿了後準備來
好那你要先敲誰先通知一下
這幾檔都有
哎呦
因為這幾檔
打三折多的都是個機會啦
朱老師的眼光被你吸引來了
他看著你
好所以現在華新科
你看華星科 哇 根本像是做富士山一樣
對啊
那通常這種現行我們看過很多
就是他做一個山之後呢
背後還會再反彈一個小土堆
是
所以呢還有一個小土堆可以讓你跑啦
所以呢各位一定要等到他出量的時候
一出量就有機會反彈
是
那反彈過程中呢
他會沒什麼解套的賣壓
是
他就會彈得比較高
那我們從籌碼來看其實
華星科的籌碼算滿漂亮的喔
哪來漂亮
這邊你看這阻力並沒有大跌
阻力並沒有大賣
走不了
對 阻力走不了
是
重點就是你看這邊一直處置
這個三角形粉紅色都是在處置
對啊
它一直在處置
不是上去處置就下去處置
它最近是下去處置
不過這個位置你看
它這個位置
它其實跌幅有點趨緩了
所以未來華新科
這一定會有一個報復性反彈
只要初量以後
好
各位可以拭目以待
出量就有機會
那我們每天照三餐煩你
好 沒問題這華欣柯第二個日電貿華欣柯跟日電貿都算跌很慘了很慘他們有一樣的狀況就是他們一直在處置這邊都是在處置的時候
那他的籌碼也是一樣
並沒有大賣
主力都賣不掉
對
因為沒有量嘛
他賣不掉
所以未來呢
主力該怎麼出
拉起來出啊
他不拉起來出
就沒量他怎麼出啊
前兩天信唱電數
是有尾盤自救
是
可是沒有救起來
那沒有用
鬧人尾盤自救
一拉13%的
那個看起來
每一個中國信託
一次買500張
一拉13%買1億
這兩天賠2000萬
是
這沒有人這樣拉的啦
那你要拉你也等他出關再來拉
好 所以這邊的話
就可能要真正的對不對
市場有一個共識
攤起來的時候有量
那就有報復性反彈
是
那或者你可以等到他們出關
那他們這些股票
被動元件我剛剛看了一下
備關時間大概剩下3天4天5天
好
也就是說下禮拜1 2 3
對
你就等著看被動元件的報復性反彈
好下禮拜1 2 3陸續出關
陸續出關
陸續出關就有機會
所以呢大盤看被動
被動反彈大盤就會彈
唉唷 哇 哥
很有信心
你的失業血越好了
光吉
對啊光吉
大家可以看一下光吉
這個也是一樣一座山
它也是一樣這邊都沒有坦
都是類似的情況
是啊
類似情況
所以只要一出量他們都有機會
因為這些地方都沒有量
然後它的主力並沒有大賣
好
這個因為被動太慘了嘛
是
現在最近人家都講一句事
問君能有幾多籌
恰是國巨買在千字頭
有點慘
國巨的諧音梗太多了
太多了
以前覺得他是奪魂劇
現在看起來是奪命劇
然後還說什麼公園相聚
剛剛那個華婆說來世再聚
哇賽不要這樣
太可憐了
我給給我一點信心
給信心
這個地板股
地板股呢
這個元大台灣50 0050
出現在地板股了
大概很少
全職股有
我很少聽到你講到0050
它代表的是一個類加權的概念
類加權概念
那它跌破這個位置其實滿正常
很多股票都跌破了很多股票的不是地盤都是地獄了那重點是什麼重點各位看一下這邊量它連跌兩天都有量
正額的量更大耶
對
也就代表說
在低檔有人在承接了
賣呢
賣你要等到有人接才會有量
那這個地方跌到有量
所以我覺得這個位置看起來是
這個0050是有機會反彈的
那零粉零反彈就大反反彈啦
那我們講一下地板股啦
那地板股呢這條線呢
是我們用統計學上來看
每次乖離到一個%數之後
有95%會反彈的線
那這線我們是用統計學算出來的
到這裡95%會反彈
但是呢你看到95%會反彈
它還不一定會反彈
但是只要有量的話
它反彈機會就會很大
所以我覺得這兩天是有機會的
因為很多人在問說
地板股到底怎麼算
其實就是用參數算
那哥有軟體
他不想要軟體的話就聽我們節目
哥有幫忙篩出來
對 幫忙篩出來
那地板價位在99
那現在收盤價有93
所以它有機會反彈的
這個乖離其實也滿大的
所以網路上一直說
我們破100減0050不是沒道理
但是有時候跌就會先超跌一下
對 會超跌
所以超跌有量的時候
其實應該接
是
好 接下來我們看
還有名門正派的台達電
剛剛朱老師可是花了一番力氣
在解釋台達電喔
阿哥要花更多的力氣解釋台達電嗎
這個在技術分析上面
怎麼樣
只要有粗量
台電有粗量了
所以不用怕
它雖然是六根黑K
有點醜
但是只要有粗量
它都有機會反彈
而且跌了42.5%
對 這麼大型股票
短時間跌10幾%
這很驚人耶
所以這麼驚人 只要有量
你看上回有量他就談了一下
所以這回有量
他會有機會反彈
好 他也跌到了地板股價位
而且他的地板價位是
也破了
現在1495
現在1495嘛
所以他其實破地板現在滿多的
但是破地板現在滿多的
在昨天他不是地板股
昨天量不夠
今天的量是超過
這個月均量的兩倍了
原來如此
這超過兩倍才有量
〔此段辨識失敗，約 10:00 起〕